هذا هو فيديو كاميرا الشرطة
للتمساح على طول الجادة الثانية، وعلى الفور نرى
التمساح يحاول التحرك بعيدًا
على طول الطريق قبل أن يندفع نحو
العشب، ويلحق به أحد الضباط الموجودين في مكان الحادث
ويتمكن من وضع
مقود أزرق حوله  قبضوا
عليه في أقل من دقيقة واحدة ووضعوه في الجزء
الخلفي من سيارة دورية،
ثم أعاده ضباط الشرطة إلى
المقر الرئيسي والتقطوا صورتين أخريين للتمساح
المحتجز قبل احتجازه
في مبنى الزنازين، تحدثنا مع نائب
الرئيس ميشيل  بدا الأمر
وكأنه كان على بعد حوالي أربعة أقدام من
الصور، حيث تمكنوا من حشره واحتوائه،
وحصلوا على
الفخ حوله، ثم
تمكنوا من وضعه في السيارة، لذلك كان
جهدًا مشتركًا ثانيًا  يقع الجادة في بيسكاتواي على
بعد حوالي ميلين من
منتزه فيكتور كرويل حيث تم رصد التمساح
الأسبوع الماضي، ومن المحتمل أنه سافر
على طول أمبروز بروك القريب قبل أن يشق
طريقه إلى
حي بيسكاتواي، هذا المكان الذي تم
العثور فيه على التمساح الليلة الماضية يقع مباشرة أمام
لم يكن لدى مات وغابي، الأخ والأخت في منزل عائلة ساليرنو، أي فكرة أن
الشرطة كانت في الخارج تحاصر
تمساحًا، أفترض أن شخصًا ما وقع في
مشكلة، لم أكن أعلم أنه كان مثل
التمساح الفعلي إذا وجدته لكنت قد
أمسكت به.  كنت سأحتفظ
بأن قسم الأسماك والحياة البرية
التقط هذا التمساح في
مقر الشرطة في حوالي منتصف الليل
وأخذوه إلى حديقة حيوان مقاطعة كيب ماي وتم
إعطاؤنا هذه الصورة عند
وصوله إلى حديقة الحيوان بعد ظهر هذا اليوم
ولكننا علمنا به.  لن يبقى في
نيوجيرسي لفترة طويلة جدًا، تقول حديقة الحيوان إنها
سترسل التمساح إلى
لقاءات كروك، وهو ملاذ يقع في
تامبا فلوريدا.